i'm laura ingram this is ingram angle
from washington tonight thanks for
joining us
first
biden's plan to destroy america that's
the focus of tonight's angle
now if you wanted to devise a plan for
america's foreign policy that worked
totally at cross purposes
you'd be hard-pressed to match what
biden and his team are doing right now
now let's go through the steps one by
one
number one
destroy america's energy independence
like we all know this he aims to
obliterate our oil and gas industry
our energy supplies from louisiana to
pennsylvania to california would power
us for about 400 years or so
but the greeniacs pulling biden strings
want it shut down and as a result well
americans are suffering
high prices for everything and still
they're climbing
and biden's sappy anecdotes about his
childhood they don't help
we're going through an incredible
transition
that is taking place that's bad
the credit the price of gas at the pump
is something that i told you you heard
me say before would be a matter of great
discussion at my kitchen table when i
was a kid growing up oh my still with
that tired old line now the transition
come on i love the meaningless
euphemisms by biden like day by day this
anti-fossil fuel obsession is making us
weaker
so we've gone from self-sufficient to
dependent
we're beggars for energy from despots
around the world
now step two is to make china rich and
powerful
competition that's healthy is good
this is the reason why i've held the
view for so many years and continue to
hold the view that a rising china is a
positive development
so of course 11 years later biden will
reward china for all that good behavior
during covid by lifting trump's tariffs
on made in china goods that enter the
united states
yeah i wish i were joking
are you considering taking down some of
those tariffs
i'm i'm talking with the secretary when
we get home i am considering it we do
not oppose any of those tariffs that are
imposed by the last administration and
they're under consideration
clearly this is what he'd like to do
lift the tariffs and the only reason
he's not done it yet is because he's
afraid of the voters
and
pathetic as it is the gop leadership
they also want them lifted like
yesterday
and our enrichment of the ccp also
extends to america's colleges and
universities that gladly matriculate
more than 300 000 chinese students every
year
now when biden was vice president the
number was about half that but he was
giddy
last year 130 000 chinese were studying
in the united states
they're really good we're going to try
to keep some of them
i'm only joking i'm only joking
they are
creepy
but high profile federal criminal
investigations of chinese spies and
academia
they should have pushed us to stop the
practice long ago but we didn't the
chairman of harvard university's
chemistry department arrested by fbi
agents charged with lying about more
than a million dollars in payments from
the chinese government
a boston university researcher accused
of being a secret operative of the
chinese military another harvard
researcher caught at the airport
allegedly trying to smuggle biological
materials to china
what could go wrong biological materials
going to china
now during the trump administration the
federal law enforcement got very serious
about stopping chinese espionage on
these college campuses but under biden
china of course is getting a free pass
now at the same time biden and many gop
old guard types want us to get deeper
into the eastern european quagmire by
sending what will undoubtedly end up
being hundreds of billions of dollars in
weapons to ukraine and that's step three
the cost of this fight
it's not cheap
but caving to aggression is going to be
more costly if we allow it to happen my
colleague senator paul has always been
basically an isolationist he's proud of
it
and believes that's where america ought
to be that is a tiny percentage of the
senate republican conference there's
always been a strand of isolationism in
our party but it's not anywhere near the
dominant view
oh really
i think mcconnell and rand paul should
tour the country and debate that 40
billion dollar price tag for ukraine in
town halls in front of all these people
and see who ends up winning the audience
vote any anyone take it wager on that
i'll take one
farcical and irresponsible are two words
i'd use to describe their arguments for
this proxy war with russia
single most important thing
we can do to push back
against potential chinese aggression
is to help the ukrainians defeat the
russians
in this current conflict
now excuse me
the globalists are responsible for
turning china into a global superpower
and the single greatest threat to
freedom worldwide
so every stinger missile we give to
ukraine is one that we're not going to
be using to defend taiwan
and they want u.s troops there as well
oh yes they do we've already upped our
numbers in eastern europe
and millie is clearly itching for more
my advice would be
to create permanent bases but don't
permanently station so you get the
effect of permanence by rotational
forces cycling through permanent bases i
believe that a lot of our european
allies they are very very willing to
establish permanent bases
they'll build them they'll pay for them
oh they'll pay for them another wager
i'll take which takes us to step four
biden will soon ship even more u.s jobs
overseas especially to asia
now when u.s manufacturers can move
operations to asia this means america is
going to become more dependent on asian
supply chains
but biden who's been wrong on literally
every trade deal he's ever voted on says
don't worry be happy
thank you all for joining today
for the launch of the indo-pacific
economic framework
for prosperity
nations represented here today are
signing up to work toward an economic
vision that will deliver for all people
where economic where economic growth is
sustainable and is inclusive
inclusive growth well they probably
think that by bribing these countries
with jobs and money
these same countries will rally to our
side when china makes its move but
that's just more naive thinking
every country from australia to
singapore will end up going with the
winner in this economic battle and if we
end up weaker they're just going to
align with china to save themselves
welcome to reality kids that's how it
works
plus as we learned at the beginning of
the pandemic when we don't make
important stuff here we lose control
and then we open ourselves up for a ton
of hurt
so we have shortages and medicines and
raw materials just to name a few
and then step five after he bankrupts us
helps china then depletes our munitions
and manpower and makes us energy poppers
well biden believes we should go to war
over taiwan
are you willing to get involved
militarily to defend taiwan if it comes
to that yes
you are
that's the commitment we made
now how do our geniuses plan to fight a
country that after steps one through
four will have become
a bigger had a bigger economy a bigger
industrial base a bigger army a bigger
air force and a bigger navy than we'll
have
how do they plan to fight a country
whose leaders were trained in our
universities and who has the best
lobbyists in washington
they couldn't out strategize the taliban
have they have even thought about
what would become of america if we lost
a war with china
i think we should be very clear here
that we will not support any more of the
establishment's wars or waste any more
money on increases in our pentagon
budget
unless we see a real effort to decouple
from the ccp we either have to change
policy
take pragmatic new steps
or
give up on taiwan which would be a
complete and utter capitulation
now think about president trump contrary
to all the unfair criticism he
understood that keeping the peace
required keeping our strength peace
through strength of course as reagan
said
but now we're back to living in this
globalist dream world
but president xi isn't
he knows how much power we have and how
much power he has
and if and when he thinks the balance of
power has shifted in china's favor he's
going to move on taiwan
and the sad fact is if they have the
money the resources and the mines
trained here they could win
so it's time to tell the establishment
it's time to choose
if you want to help finland and sweden
and nato because of putin's aggression
okay that's fine
but let's stop pretending there's a
pivot to asia that matters you cannot do
both
their plan is to strengthen our enemies
weaken us then go fight more wars
trump's plan was to weaken our enemies
strengthen ourselves and avoid new wars
makes sense right it's common sense
our nation is hurting you can feel it
right
our people are pessimistic it's horrible
to see that
they're beginning to think that our
political leaders
don't know how to turn things around
even if they wanted to
every week when they look at their
family budgets americans have to make
hard choices
call me crazy but i think it's time that
washington started doing the same
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else